As I said, fortunately, every file read is not
going to result in going through so many hoops to
get the data blocks. This is where caches come
into play. So when you start with a filename and,
and an offset on a client node, you look
up the directory. And from that, you get an index
and an offset. So, this is a data structure
which is in the client memory, and once you get
the index in the offset, and if this file
has been accessed before, it's most likely in its own
unique cache. This is a file cache of the
file system, and if it is in your cache, then
you get the data block. In other words, going
from the file name to the data block that is
associated with the file is all happening through the
client memory because of local caching. And there's a fastest
path for file access and hopefully there's a common
case. Now it is possible that a file is
shared. Or the same file is being read by
different clients at different points in time, but in
either case, there is a possibility that a particular
file has been accessed by a client and therefore
in the cache of that client, and so the
next possibility is that you start with a directory
You don't find it in you local cache. And if
you don't find it in your local cache, then you have
to go to the manager node in order to get
a copy of the file. So this is where the manager
map data structure, which is a replicated data structure, is
available in the memory of every client and so given the
index number and the offset. I can go and look
up the manager map data structure and that tells me who's
the manager that I have to contact to get
this particular file. So this might involve a network
cop because the manager node is different from the
local node. Then I have to go to the manager
node across a network. And when I get to
the manager node, the manager node may say, oh
you know what, this particular file, has been accessed
by a different client. I know that because my metadata
says that some of the client has got this,
in their cache. So, the manager will tell the client
that currently is holding a copy of the file
in its cache. To please send the data over to
the first guy that requested it. Now, the data
that I requested is coming not from my local cache,
but it is coming from the cache of a peer.
And that's much better than going to the disk and
putting it out of the disk, because network speeds
are much faster than accessing the disk. So this is
the second best path for file access. Sure, there is
network communication involved here because, the first thing I that
have to do is I have to hop over the
network to get to the manager node if in fact
I am not the manager node myself for this particular
file that I'm looking for. That is a network hop.
And there could be another network hop if the manager
says, oh, this particular file is cached in a different
node. In that case, there is another network hop to
go to the client that currently containing that particular file.
And once we get to that, there may be another
network hop in order to send the data over to
the requester. So potentially there could be three network hops
in order to get The file that I'm looking for,
but it could be less than that depending on the core location of the manager and
the node that is requesting it or the
manager and the node that contains a copy of
that file itself. So this is the second best path for file access. But there is
also the pathologically 'real long way' of accessing
a particular file, and that path is shown here,
using all of the data structures that I
mentioned earlier that is available at the manager. You
start with a file name, look up the
directory, get the index number and the offset. It's
not in your cache. You go to the
manager by looking up the manager map data structure
that's in my local memory. I go the
manager and the manager then looks up its metadata
for this file, finds that nobody has it in
the cache So it has to pull it from the
desk. If it has to pull it from the desk, then it has to look up its imap data
structure, the imap data structure, and the stripe group map data structure
in order to find out the location of the I node that
corresponds to the log segment that I am looking for. That look up happens
through the imap data structure, stripe group
map data structure, then I can to the
storage server and get the index node of the log segment ID for the requested
data block of this client. Once I have that, then the manager has to look up the
stripe group map to see what storage servers. Have this log segment striped,
and out of that which storage server should I
contact for the particular portion of the file that
you're looking for? And that storage server will be
contacted and that storage server is going to give the
data block that is requested by the client. So
you can see that in this long path, there
is network hop as well as accessing the storage
servers to pull the data blocks. It is possible that
the index node for the log segment ID
associated with this file has been previously accessed by
this manager. In which case, it doesn't have to
go to the storage server to get the Index
node for the large segment, because it'll be present
in the memory of the manager as part of
its caching strategy. And therefore it can bypass these
two network hops because directly from this strip group
map it can figure out what the long segment ID is locally cached so that it can
then go to this stripe group map data structure
and figure out. Where on the disk the data
blocks for that log segment is actually secured, so
we might be able to get rid of at
least two of these network hops if you're lucky
and this particular log segment has been accessed before
by this manager, it'll be in the memory
of the manager. And therefore we can avoid these
two network hubs. But the worst case scenario,
if this particular log segment is never being accessed
before then the long way to get to
the data block that you're requesting is going through
the data structures in the manager, network hub, storage
look up, and get the data and give it
to the client.